I have a decent amount of credit card
debt along with debt in general how much
debt you got um between uh house credit
card Vehicles we're about uh 350 how
much of that's house
290 okay so you got 60,000 how much of
that cars uh about 30 to 40 okay so you
got 30,000 in credit card debt what's
your household income or about 100,000
great so you make 100 you owe 60 in this
Consumer Debt so the question is how
much margin can we create to throw extra
on the debt and we're going to follow
the debt snowball method that's the way
10 million people have followed it it's
the same way I got out of 40 Grand in
debt and so you have how many debts
three or is it more than that total
between the car loans and the credit
card is it multiple
cards uh no it just it's One credit card
and honestly I really didn't even want
to get a credit card to begin with
fortunately but you know when you become
a homeowner it's one of those things
that where you you got to have it as
like a backup plan well a backup plan
would be your own money like having an
emergency fund where you become the